may I have her attention
emergency exit doors are located
please take a few minutes
please enter the account and orderly
fashion
follow the directions of the human
versus
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
good morning
please be seated
I invite you all to silence your phones
welcome to the commencement exercises
for the Yale physician assistant online
program
my name is Alexandria garino and I'm the
associate Dean for PA education
on behalf of this Yale School of
Medicine and of PA education I welcome
family friends
the PA program faculty and staff
our instructional faculty and preceptors
and of course our graduates
we are very fortunate to have with us
today Dr Jessica aluzi Deputy Dean for
medical education
and Dr Mark perazella the PA program's
medical director and our commencement
speaker
thank you all for joining us as we
celebrate the accomplishments of the
class of 2023.
welcome to New Haven on this glorious
day
we appreciate your joining us especially
knowing that all of you have traveled
great distances to be here today you've
come to Woolsey Hall from Far and Away
take a moment to look around and really
appreciate where we are I'm always
struck by the beauty of Woolsey Hall
pretty magnificent place
what a wonderful place to celebrate
commencement
and what an appropriate place
you see Pomp and Circumstance number one
the music you just marched to Was Heard
for the first time at a commencement
ceremony right here in 1905.
and probably played on the same
magnificent pipe organ you see behind me
Edward Elgar the composer received an
honorary degree that year
and as a tribute to him his own March
was played as the graduates left the
hall
it's now one of the most famous pieces
of music that is associated with
commencements around the world and it
started right here at Yale
pretty amazing
your education started at Yale as well
it seems very fitting that we celebrate
here in Woolsey Hall
and celebrate your work dedication and
perseverance over the last 28 months
and to Mark the beginning of your
professional careers
it's now my great pleasure to introduce
interim program director Elizabeth
Rossler
director Rossler graduated from Emery's
PA program in 1992.
she is a gifted clinician and a gifted
educator who has dedicated her
professional life to providing Quality
Health Care to the underserved and
disenfranchised and to developing future
PA clinicians
a native of Connecticut director Rossler
has worked at federally qualified health
centers in New Haven was the director of
the Community Health Care van in the
section of HIV medicine and has been the
co-medical director of The Haven
student-run free clinic for many years
you can find her on many Saturday
mornings attending patients and working
with students at Haven
director Rossler has made a tremendous
difference in the lives of many patients
and students in her career
and before being named interim director
in November 2022 director Rossler
managed the first year curriculum for
the physician associate program for nine
years so she is a very dedicated
educator of PA students
please join me in welcoming director
Rossler to the podium
[Applause]
good morning and welcome and welcome to
those that are viewing from afar through
our live stream it is my honor to
introduce our commencement speaker mark
parizella Dr perazella is a
board-certified nephrologist and
professor of medicine in the Department
of Medicine section of nephrology at
Yale School of Medicine and the VA
Medical Center at in West Haven
Connecticut his academic career is
centered on his role as a clinician and
educator he is currently the director of
acute dialysis program at the Yale New
Haven Hospital and medical director for
both the Yale physician assistant online
and El physician associate programs
he's been honored both locally and
nationally for his clinical work in
Nephrology and his role as an educator
he was given the Yale Primary Care
Program teacher of the year award in
1995. the Yale Department of internal
medicine achievement and education Award
in 2005 and the Yale Nephrology
leadership and education award in 2014.
he has received two lifetime achievement
awards at the national level
the National Kidney Foundation awarded
him the Donald W Selden award for
excellence in clinical Nephrology in
2021 and the American Society of
nephrology awarded him with the Robert G
narens award for excellence in education
and teaching in 2022.
he's editor-in-chief for the Journal of
onco-nephrology Deputy editor for kidney
360. section editor for Aki for the
clinical Nephrology he serves on the
editorial board for the clinical Journal
of the American Society of nephrology
American Journal of Medicine and
American Journal of kidney diseases
he has published over 350 articles
written numerous book chapters and is
co-edited five textbooks
but more importantly he is a supporter
and promoter of Pas and Pa education and
I think we are fortunate
fortunate Yale to call Mark a mentor and
a friend
[Applause]
well it's really really a privilege and
an honor to be here excuse me today
I love you know I've been here at Yale
for 30 years and and I love this
tradition of graduation and and the
ceremonies it's just wonderful so I want
to say to you good morning and welcome
it's really nice to have you all here
and it's really great to see you all
because this is an important and
exciting ceremony as we celebrate the
achievements as you've heard the Yale
physician assistant online class of 2023
80 new PA strong so awesome
now I'm a nephrologist as you heard and
I I talk a lot about kidney disease but
you'll you will be spared any Nephrology
lectures today I'm going to talk about
you guys and what I've done and I think
what you guys can do
first of all I would like to start by
thanking the Pian Lund program for
inviting me to deliver this commencement
address for the ceremony it's truly an
honor to be here
I'd also like to recognize Deputy Dean
for education at Lucy associate Dean for
Education Guarino
NP online program director Rossler
really really great to be with them on
the stage I'd also like to recognize and
extend huge kudos to the outstanding
faculty and staff who have made this
important day possible for you guys the
Yale graduates so great job you guys
all right
thank you so where do I begin this
morning well first and foremost I want
to emphasize that this day is all about
congratulating you guys the graduates
the fourth cohort of students in this
program
this is your day so please enjoy it
is also equally important to recognize
your families
spouses significant others and friends
who have supported you throughout this
entire challenging Endeavor really
important their support and
encouragement cannot be underestimated
so I want to thank all of you for your
kind and persistent support of The
Graduate so round of applause for the
support
so what about you guys well as a Yale
class of 2023 you are quite diverse in
very many ways that's not surprising for
an online program that covers a lot of
territory you come from 27 States and
have many varied backgrounds they range
from former medical laboratory and
surgical technologists physical and
respiratory therapists dental hygienists
personal trainers counselors dietitians
phlebotomists firefighters nurses Medics
and so many more in fact the trainees in
this program come from 45 different
backgrounds that's really impressive so
congratulations
you have completed 28 months of rigorous
training you have worked really hard and
you have now reached the Holy Grail as
newly mentioned physician assistants and
you're now ready to practice your trade
as such
as I will warn you you are going to
plunge head first into an ever-changing
and often challenging world of Health
Care
this is exciting this is daunting and
this is frightening
but fear not fear not you have been well
extremely well trained by your
outstanding faculty and preceptors and
you're ready to enter into an
interesting and exciting journey in
medicine you really are it'll be fun
as you go forward remember remember this
is not just a job or a gig to make ends
meet it is a special vocation it's an
important Mission and it's a privilege
to be able to provide care for the sick
and prevent illness and the healthy
so you heard a very nice introduction
about me but frankly I am most
passionate about my vocation both as a
clinician and an educator sort of what I
do like all of you I started out as a
wide-eyed and anxious trainee who
eventually over time transitioned to a
faculty member at Yale
along that path I learned that the best
way to help patients was to not only
develop my own clinical skills
but to also grow as a teacher gain
experience as a mentor
and take it to the next level I'm with
these still skills I thought I could
effectively teach students residents
fellows my own colleagues and my
patients
My Hope Is that participating in the
training of scores of competent and
caring Health Care Providers would go a
long way in helping to provide the
workforce we needed to serve our
patients because after all at the end of
the day that is our ultimate end game is
to provide good care to our patients
during my many years at Yale more than
. my day job has included as you heard
clinical research editorial and
administrative responsibilities some
Nephrology Society work however as I
said most most of my times as a faculty
member has been spent as a clinical
nephrologist and a teacher what we call
the proverbial clinician educator I
worked really hard to become a solid
clinician an Effective Teacher it takes
a lot of work
I developed skills as a mentor again
took more work and learned to be learned
that being a mentor wasn't enough that
being a sponsor was important and I'll
get to that later
but I'd like to spend the rest of my
time talking
to you about your roles as clinicians
teachers mentors and potentially
sponsors and how each of these roles
ultimately relates to you as you're
starting to enter the healthcare Arena
so let's start with your role as
clinicians this is what you've been
trained to do for the the past couple
years
perhaps the most important thing you
will do as you start out as new
practitioners is to provide competent
and Compassionate Care
this will take time and effort you don't
know everything entering and it's going
to take work as you advance in your
careers you will gain more experience
hone your Diagnostic and therapeutic
skills and ultimately become more
knowledgeable but remember this takes
dedication to lifelong learning and an
open mind to receiving feedback from
your colleagues from your supervisors
and from your patients be diligent and
detail-oriented but don't forget to be
compassionate that's so important
over time you will develop into Health
Care Providers from whom patients will
derive great benefit
they will trust you and in doing so you
will form a strong therapeutic
relationship
but being great clinicians is not all
that you are limited to Great clinicians
are inherently great teachers
so let's talk about your role as
teachers
what qualities do effective teachers
possess when you when you think about
that I think we all have a pretty good
idea what great teachers look like they
don't just prevent facts and information
they connect with the audience so that
the material presented is understood and
easily digested great teachers are able
to assess their audience engage if
they're understanding the material being
presented and if they're actually
enjoying the lecture that was hard to do
over Zoom I must tell you
and this this Behavior holds for whether
you're lecturing to a conference room of
of participants whether you're just
talking to a few trainees and colleagues
at the bedside or you're advising your
patients and their families in an exam
room
I want to emphasize that teaching your
patients and families is incredibly
important
as Healthcare Providers we must do all
we can to improve health care Literacy
for our patients
many of you will no doubt no doubt
become excellent teachers but some of
you may also transition to what are
formal Educators role and what do I mean
by that well great teachers can take
their skills to the next level by
teaching in the classroom directing
didactic and clinical courses designing
and implementing curricula and creating
novel teaching and assessment tools look
to your own faculty for great example of
innovative educators really truly
all right let's move on what about your
role as mentors we're moving higher
along the level is this a potential for
your future
I think it is
mentors need to have multiple skills I
believe the most important is their role
as an advocate for their mentee really
important to be an advocate the mentor
mentee relationship is grounded in trust
and respect
mentors understand the strengths and
limitations of their mentee and in doing
so are able to connect with the mentee
to know and understand where they are
where they're going
and how to get there
mentors provide General career advice
advocate for wellness provide Behavior
modeling and sometimes connect or mentee
with other experts who can provide more
information many of you will have this
opportunity as you grow and mature in
your profession
finally what about sponsors
you know what is a sponsor what is what
does that term mean well actually early
in my career I was unaware of the
sponsor phenotype I really didn't know
what it was
um I wasn't sure how this person would
be different than a mentor well it turns
out sponsors are much more than just
mentors on steroids to my way of
thinking the simplest definition is as
follows
mentors chart the path for the mentee
while sponsors clear that path and have
the things happen for you typically the
sponsors are late mid-career senior
level person someone like me or somebody
The Faculty for sure and they usually
have a leadership role in some
organization
they have lots of experience and
numerous connections they open doors and
create opportunities for their mentees
so let's Circle back to you guys
how does this discussion about
clinicians and teachers and mentors and
sponsors impact you as you begin your
careers in medicine
clearly as competent clinicians you will
have tremendous impact on patient care
and their clinical outcomes
many of you will practice primary care
and provide health care for many of the
under represented minorities in the
indigene that's a really important
mission
some of you will become specialists in
the various venues available in Medicine
and you will do those same things in
those specialties
regardless of your practice specialty
your patients will greatly benefit from
receiving care from compassionate
knowledgeable and competent health care
providers who can relate to them and
present complex medical information in a
clear and understandable way
just remember the patients receiving
this information are overwhelmed and
it's your job to to make the information
clear to them
during during your many months of
rigorous clinical training you learn the
how-to part of clinical medicine and
clinical practice from your faculty
and they did a great job
in addition to that training during your
didactic and clinical parts of your
training your program faculty and your
assigned to academic advisors helped you
navigate
the training they solve problems and
likely of advising you about future jobs
thus this dedicated group of Educators
and mentors transformed and molded you
into skilled Health Care Providers ready
to practice clinical medicine with
competence and compassion
really important job and they've done it
well what you probably don't appreciate
is that in addition to being students
who are trained to be excellent
clinicians you all feeling good about
that along the way you actually were
becoming teachers you were teaching your
classmates you were teaching your
faculty I learned every day from my my
residents and fellows
and you're also teaching your patients
and you've been doing that all along
during your training so with this
experience under your belts I predict
that as you progress and evolve in your
careers you will grow and mature as
teachers and for your students who you
will likely precept in the future when
you're out there practicing as well as
for your patients and colleagues
but you don't have to stop there you can
develop your skills to become formal
Educators like your faculty to carry
forward the tradition of teaching and
Advising students if you choose a path
in PA education you can become Educators
and mentors and chart the path for your
future Pas and some of you may as you as
you become more experienced and and and
grow older like me become future
sponsors and help clear that path
Mentor charts it sponsor clears it so as
I previously said our end game for all
the end game for all of us is to provide
top-notch medical care for our patients
you will do this as outstanding
clinicians teachers and mentors and as
such create a pipeline of competent and
compassionate health care providers
that will ultimately execute our mission
all of you are going to be part of that
important mission
so I'm going to end here I hope I was
able to provide some insight into my
passion as a clinician educator and my
visions of the various roles involved in
medical education I also want them to
impress upon you you have an exciting
future ahead of you with so many
interesting opportunities
I would like to once again congratulate
the Yale Pian graduating cast of 2023
well done
enjoy the moment and get ready for the
next step and again I want to
congratulate the faculty and staff for
their tireless dedication to training
another group of extraordinary Pas who
are renting the field of Health Care job
well done
thank you very much for allowing me the
honor of speaking at your commencement
and have a great time today thank you
it's now my distinct pleasure to invite
Jessica Lucy to the podium
Dr aluzi is the dean for education at
the Yale School of Medicine
[Applause]
congratulations to the 80 members of the
physician assistant online class of
2023. wow
I am honored to have the opportunity to
speak on this celebratory day for you
and your families
you are the fourth class to graduate
from the aopa online program
we now have nearly 250 alumni of the
program spread across the country
this is both exciting and impactful
advancing one of Yale's goals when it
created the PA online program to help
address the shortage of primary care
providers across the United States
you began the program in January 2021
less than a year into the covid-19
pandemic
I am grateful to you for wanting to
serve in a profession where providing
care to others is the highest priority
at a time when you knew you would be on
the front lines putting yourself at risk
to help others
as early as spring of 2021 just one year
into the pandemic you were engaging with
patients through seed the clinical
experience in early didactic
while the Stars cov2 virus is still
circulating and causing severe illness
and hospitalizations thankfully due to
advances in science and medicine we are
in a very different place than we were
when you started the program
in fact just yesterday on May 11th the
White House ended the covid-19 public
health emergency
one of the many positive benefits of
this change is that we can easily gather
together in this beautiful space for
this ceremony celebrating our graduates
I'd also like to pause and thank the
families and friends as others have
for all that you have done to support
your family members and students in the
very rigorous PA online program
to our graduates you all should be very
very proud of your accomplishments you
have been part of an Innovative program
that has trained you to be outstanding
patient-centered clinicians experienced
in being part of a healthcare team
you worked extraordinarily hard
during the 28 months of your program
including engaging in 120 more hours of
clinical care during your didactic year
followed by 15 months of intensive
clinical rotations
I know all of you will provide
Compassionate Care to your patients and
contribute valuably to the medical
profession
as we all know the pandemic dramatically
changed the world view on remote
learning
and the Yale PA online program had a
head start in leading the way in how to
creatively use technology to make online
learning powerfully engaging
I want to thank our PA online faculty
and staff for their leadership and
creativity in this effort and I want to
thank and congratulate this year's
commencement speaker Dr Mark parizella
Dr perazella has served as the medical
director for both of the school of
medicine's PA programs for many years
and has been a tremendous Advocate as
you've heard for the importance of PA
education at Yale like our students Dr
perazella is entering a new phase of
life as he soon will be retiring being
at Yale since 1988 when he arrived for a
primary care internship
as I stated one of the reasons Yale
created the PA online program
to help address the shortage of primary
care providers across across the United
States
this program uniquely supports students
to live learn and eventually work in
their home communities
your class comes from over 26 States 22
percent of you live in rural areas 28
percent in medically underserved
communities this Geographic diversity
shows the potential of this program to
have a positive impact on our country's
Health Care needs
wherever your career leads you whether
you're in your home Community or a new
location whether practicing Primary Care
as many of you will do or in a specialty
practice you will provide much needed
care to your future patients
your class also reflects the PA
program's commitment to promote
diversity and an inclusive environment
by continuously engaging in education
reflection and advocacy for the benefit
of the communities in which we learn
work and serve
37 percent of you are first in your
family to attend college and 28 percent
are underrepresented in medicine
themselves additionally 17 percent are
veterans or active military the breadth
of your lived experience has benefited
your class and will benefit your
patients
today you join a wide network of Yale
University alumni around the world
please stay connected to each other and
to the Yale School of Medicine we are
very proud to have you all as graduates
congratulations
[Applause]
my name is Diane Russo
I am the director of Justice Equity
diversity and inclusion for the pay
program and an assistant professor
adjunct in the department of internal
medicine
and it is my great honor to introduce my
advisees
all right
Monica Jeanette Bass
[Applause]
Alexandria Ann bozen
foreign
Guzman
[Applause]
Tony Hanley
Nicole D Hoff
[Applause]
Troy a pero
congrats
Miguel a Reyes
[Applause]
congratulations
rookie fan Truong
[Applause]
congratulations
and Derek Woods congratulations
[Applause]
congratulations
good morning my name is John kilstrom
I'm an assistant professor adjunct with
the program and I will now be announcing
my advisees
Arjun but try
[Applause]
Kristen brockler
Megan Elizabeth Cannon
[Applause]
Joe Elizabeth Davis
Elizabeth Grace Eddie
[Applause]
Geralyn Ayo Sabio
[Music]
[Applause]
Jamie Hill
Caitlin Arya kikafer
[Applause]
Morgan Myrick
Deborah Palmer
[Applause]
Aaron Phillips
Jacob Aaron regelsperger
[Applause]
Carlos Manuel Suarez Jr
Emily Marie waldketter
[Applause]
congratulations
good morning I'm Janie McDaniel I am the
director of alumni Affairs and also the
Emeritus chair of admissions for the
aopa online program and I'm happy to
introduce my advisees who are graduating
in the class of 2023.
Carrie Lynn Claussen
[Applause]
Taylor Cully
Justin m edgel
[Applause]
Alyssa Irene fredbeau
Dana Dowry Zhang
[Applause]
Holly Kane
Ellen Catherine Kenny
[Applause]
Joseph D Mariano
Jessica Russell
[Applause]
Gregory McClelland Shields
Andrea Sparr
[Applause]
Amelia Christine Toomey
foreign
Young
[Applause]
good morning my name is Stephanie Neary
I'm an assistant professor adjunct with
the pi online program and the director
of didactic education so
um Sarah colon
[Applause]
Trisha Davis
thank you
Abigail finkenauer
[Applause]
kellyanne Gardner
Kita Griffith
[Applause]
kelsia Hopkins
Emily muff
[Applause]
Joshua stockhausen
Jennifer Stroup
[Applause]
Brennan Taylor
Jessie Young
[Applause]
hi my name is Mary showstark I'm
assistant professor to the program and
director of virtual interprofessional
education I'm here to announce my
advisees and I'm so proud of you all so
I'm excited so proud of you all so
Stacy glass
[Applause]
Noel cavity
uh Sarah Kirsch
[Applause]
Salvador Luna
all right Michael pepke
[Applause]
Aaron Riley
Christina Ruiz
[Applause]
Alexandria Scully
foreign
[Applause]
Tyler Williams
Crystal excello
[Applause]
Ashley Zito
I was reveling in all the happiness and
I forgot what I was supposed to do next
I'd like to invite Amelia Toomey up here
class president for the ad student
address
[Applause]
[Music]
oh wow this is a different perspective
up here okay hi my name is Amelia and I
was just introduced I'm the class
president for the class of 2023 in
today's elected graduation speaker so
welcome fellow graduates faculty staff
family and friends I want to begin with
some well-deserved thank yous thank you
to our faculty and staff who have worked
to guide and educate US during this
process of becoming compassionate and
competent providers as you've seen today
we all had faculty advisors and I
simply would not be here without mine
they are guides for us and I am so
thankful to them
a special thank you to Professor van ree
who spent the beginning of our program
guiding us and educating us and thank
you to our interim director Liz who
introduced me for serving as our M term
director over the last few months
thank you to my fellow classmates
to say the least we've been through a
lot together
late night study sessions clinical wins
for our patients and unfortunately
clinical losses
I can say without with absolute
certainty each and every one of you
individually are the reason that we
stand here together today as a cohort
graduating
to that end I want to thank all of my
classmates who selflessly scared shared
their skills to ensure each one of us
made it to this Finish Line
so some special thank yous a special
thank you to Ellen
[Applause]
[Music]
whose life-saving charts are the
single-handed reason that I passed
Anatomy
to the makers and educators of all
things Anki Chris Christian Emily I'm
talking to you
to Aaron
whose consistence in creating these
beautiful long artistic reviews for us
on every topic kept it interesting kept
me focused at 2 am
to the creators of our custom slack
emojis the gym emojis the bird emojis
you are the real MVPs who made sure we
could all express our points with
perfectly accurate human humor and
lightness
to those who made our custom Jim vanry
t-shirts and stickers your graphic
design skills are unmatched and we are
forever grateful for the unique
keepsakes
to all who participated in our most
vital and important slack channel the
meme Channel
hilarious memes
uh you are not only appreciated on tough
days but you also reassured me that I
was not the only one whose sanity was
questionably fleeting on a daily basis
to all of the pet parents whose furry
friends or in some cases less furry for
our friend Emily and her hairless cat
ensured that we never had a dull Zoom
meeting or a cat booty list meeting
thank you to our families our loved ones
and friends we simply would not be here
without you today it was not just us who
accepted the commitment of PA school
when we started down this path in
January 2021 your tireless support love
and understanding allowed all of us to
utilize the time resources and mental
space required to succeed on our
Journeys and becoming pas
a final thank you to all who are in
attendance today here in New Haven and
virtually to celebrate this glorious
conclusion to three intense challenging
and joyful years of PA School
looking back
I have to say that our program at the
time
that we joining the program at the time
that we did feels a bit Brave and a
little bit crazy
we accepted a seat in the very first
online hybrid PA program to ever exist
in the midst of a global pandemic and
before the first class had even reached
graduation
we embarked on this journey together and
we all gained many experiences skills
and life lessons from being part of this
flag Flagship experience for hybrid
medical education
I can tell you from my personal
experience not every day was easy but it
was worth it
if our cohort is remembered for one
thing
I believe it will be fierce advocacy
amazing strides have been made by this
cohort to better pa education not just
for our class but for all future cohorts
NPA students Nationwide and I want to
share some of those today because our
families deserve to hear them on this
momentous day of remembering all of you
some of these projects include but are
certainly not limited to becoming the
first online program to obtain
representation with the Yale graduate
student Senate which was no small feat a
project fearlessly led by Jamie Hill
creation of a peer student resource
committee by Jacob regelsberger Ellen
Carlos Andy and Kelly for future cohorts
that will carry on for years
this committee assists students with
resources and information for a smooth
start and transition into the LPA online
program and students for years to come
will benefit from your hard work thank
you so much
[Applause]
another special shout out for fierce
fierce advocacy by Jacob regelsberger
for PA students access to health care
and insurance both within our
institution but also on a national level
at the annual aapa 2022 conference
before the house of delegates an amazing
feat
foreign
the creation of Wellness social and
Faith committees we have great gratitude
for all of the individual student
leaders who devoted their time effort
and energy to ensuring these committees
met the needs of their peers in every
aspect of their lives
con contributing to
an improvement in the clinical placement
process for future cohorts through data
collection and advocacy
every single person's input matters and
I know that future cohorts will benefit
from the work that we put in
members of our cohort have worked on a
great deal of individual State Pas PA
laws and scope of practice
advocacy and projects and finally
members of our cohort have spent
significant time advocating for more
sensitive trauma-informed care and
training in PA education thank you
Nicole
to underscore the importance of the
educational Journey we have endured
I would like to invite our friends and
families in the audience and our
graduates
to please stand when you hear a
statement that applies to someone you
know
please stand and remain standing until
everyone is asked to be seated again
please stand if you know someone who has
experienced
provider biases and or discrimination
when attempting to access medical care
please stand if you know someone who
needed access to high quality Care
judgment-free Mental Health Care but for
one reason or another didn't receive it
please stand if you know someone who did
not have a health care provider for a
medical specialty visit within
reasonable driving distance to their
home
please stand if you know someone who has
avoided seeing a health care provider
based on a past adverse experience with
an individual provider or the overall
medical system
please stand if you know someone who has
experienced provider bias or
discrimination when attempting to access
care
please stand if you or a loved one will
refuse care or receive lower Quality
Care based on sex or gender identity
please stand if you or a loved one or
someone you know needed high quality
judgment-free obstetric or gynecologic
care in your community but it was not
available
please stand if you struggle to get care
because there was not a provider who
spoke your native language
please stand and remain standing if you
know someone who has struggled to obtain
health insurance or affordable medical
care
now I ask everyone please look around
you
so many people standing please be seated
for each person in this room who stood
today
there is a provider in this room there
is a PA in this room
who will make their life passion to
ensure that someone like you knew
someone who you stood for will never
have to face that same barrier to Health
Care again
foreign
every barrier that our patients
encounter we are committed to making an
enormous difference in the lives of our
patients and our communities and this is
why we are here today
if the members of this cohort continue
with even one percent of their hard work
and advocacy that they have displayed
during this program I have no doubt the
world will be a better place not just
for Pas but for our patients so today I
leave you with this challenge
find the one thing in medicine that
makes you feel deeply emotional whether
it be passion discomfort distress Rage
or joy
when something you encounter in medicine
evokes that strong emotion let that be a
reminder that there is work to be done
and I propose that we be the ones to do
it
be The Advocate
and the action taker that your patients
need and slowly there will be fewer
people standing in this room
congratulations to the class of 2023 oh
my goodness we made it
[Applause]
if the inductees of Pai Alpha would
please
come line up
so Pi Alpha is the national physician
assistant Honor Society sponsored by the
physician assistant education
Association
and organized for the promotion and
recognition of both PA students and
graduates
membership signifies inductee's
significant academic achievements and
honors them for their leadership
research
community and Professional Service and
other related activities
the society also encourages a high
standard of character and conduct among
students and graduates
Arjun betrayed
[Applause]
eruberto Cruz Guzman
[Music]
congratulations
Ali fredbeau
[Applause]
congratulations
Kelly Ann Gardner
[Music]
foreign
Hanley
[Applause]
Holly Kane
[Music]
Sarah Kirsch
[Applause]
Aaron Phillips
congrats
Jacob Aaron regelsperger
[Applause]
Greg McClelland Shields
Brennan K Taylor
[Applause]
I would also like to take a moment to
recognize the faculty recognition of our
inductees into Pi Alpha for this year
Dr Mark perazella
[Applause]
Elizabeth Rossler
and Janie McDaniel
[Applause]
okay
Amelia that was really one of the best
student addresses I've ever heard
and I would take that
and it resonated with me you know
professionally that's kind of how I
worked but I would take that and be the
change that you want to see in health
care you starting tomorrow or maybe this
afternoon have that opportunity to
change Health Care
so would you class of 2023 please rise
to recite the oath
this is the physician assistant
professional oath
I pledge to perform the following duties
with honesty integrity and dedication
and remembering always
that my primary responsibility is to
health safety welfare and dignity of all
human beings
I recognize and promote the value of
diversity
and will treat all equally all persons
who seek my care
and ever since non-maleficence Justice
and the principle of informed consent
I will hold in confidence the
information shared in the course
of medicine except where I am authorized
to impart such knowledge
I will be diligent in understanding both
my personal capabilities and my
limitations striving always to improve
my practice of Medicine
I will actively seek to expand my
Knowledge and Skills keeping abreast of
advances in Medical Art and Science
I will work with other members of the
health care team to assure compassionate
and effective care of patients
I will uphold and enhance Community
Values and use the knowledge and
experience acquired as a PA to
contribute to an improved community
I will respect my professional
relationship with Physicians and other
members of the health care team
I recognize my duty to perpetuate
knowledge within this profession
these Duties are pledged with sincerity
and upon my honor
so I'd like to have us offer a round of
applause
for the class of 2023
well done
and to and to the class of 2023 that are
home
watching virtually
sorry you couldn't be here with us
okay
so
this is it's over right you're
officially graduated but we have of
course we always have instructions and
final words so if we could have everyone
sit
and have the guests and family remain
seated as the faculty and the students
um
process proceed I guess proceed out and
then you can meet your loved ones out in
the by Nicki Courtyard where we're all
Gathering early because that rotunda
area gets very crowded very quickly
um we will see you at a reception down
at the Elm City Club 150
um Elm Street
um and see you there for a celebration
lunch
thank you
[Applause]
foreign
thank you
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]